[Music]
hey guys it's katie and i'm here with my
husband chris hey and we are back in the
kitchen we haven't been here for a
little bit yeah it's been a while but
we're excited that we're all back here
together and it's getting kind of cold
it's getting kind of cozy and i wanted
to roast a chicken ooh that sounds
delicious i love chicken but i thought
wouldn't it be cool to ask all of my
friends about their favorite cooking
tips and i've assembled several of those
tips to make what i hope to be the best
roast chicken recipe ever that sounds
really good you've assembled your dream
team it sounds like kind of like the
avengers of the cookie the thing you get
to do is come in at the end as always
we're gonna taste it together and we're
gonna see if it truly is an amazing
recipe that sounds great let's make
chicken magic in three two one
okay hi hi so to get started i have
about a five pound whole chicken here so
the first thing we're gonna do before we
do anything is pat this guy dry with the
paper towel you wanna make sure you get
all that moisture off and moisture is
the enemy of crispiness also make sure
that you get inside the cavity and try
that out as well okay so now that we've
patted him dry this first tip comes from
my friend mimo hey katie here's my one
tip for you i like to sew my chicken the
night before which is called a dry brine
this helps
give your chicken more flavor and a
crispy skin i've never done a dry brine
before because usually when i'm roasting
a chicken it like happens in the moment
and i'm like i want to do it tonight i'm
going to do what mimo says i'm going to
season this guy all over with salt i
usually like salt and pepper mimo's the
purist and she says just salt but i'm
excited to see if it actually helps like
really add more flavor to the chicken
and make it much more crispy it's also
really important that you put some
seasoning inside the cavity that around
so we're going to transfer this to a
baking sheet because that salt's really
going to draw out the moisture and we
want that to go somewhere and we're
going to put this in the fridge
uncovered overnight so make sure nothing
in your fridge is touching it you don't
want any salmonella i'll see you guys in
the morning
hello it's day two i hope everyone slept
well our chicken he's definitely got
some moisture that's come into this pan
he's looking a little funky i think
that's everything that's supposed to be
happening so i'm going to put him off to
the side
this next step comes from my friend
kelly and i have never heard of it
before hey katie here is my tip for
amazing mercedes chicken i actually like
to use mayonnaise instead of butter and
i rub that all over the top of the skin
and under it it's going to give it great
flavor a beautiful even golden brown
color and you won't have to keep facing
it because mayonnaise is thicker than
butter so you're just going to stay put
you don't do any extra work so good luck
and let me know what you think i have
never used mayo on a roast chicken but
i'm always down to try something new
i've got about six ounces of mayo here i
am gonna add in some orange zest i love
the smell of fresh zest anything citrus
make sure you don't zest down to this
white part because that's called the
pith and it's super bitter i think that
that's quite enough of zest next thing
we're gonna add is some fresh thyme and
i actually learned a hack just today
that i'm very excited to show you guys
about with thyme and even rosemary you
know it can be really tedious to have to
pluck off each little individual piece
so to save you time
[Music]
i did not do that on purpose i'm going
to take the time
and place it between one of the holes
and this gently pull it through and look
at it it's peeling it off it's so easy
to do and so quick so we'll add our time
to our mixture there a little garlic
powder and then freshly cracked pepper
i am obsessed with pepper i think i said
it earlier i'm gonna say it again i am a
pepper princess
and then we'll just mix this together
that is looking so gorgeous so this next
part i'm going to prepare actually comes
from a tip from my aunt and my mom hi
katie this is your aunt pat and your mom
and we're here to give you some advice
on how to roast a chicken i like to
roast my chicken with a quartered orange
inside well i like to leave my orange
whole and poke holes in it i like big
sprigs of a tarragon in mine well i like
rosemary well
good luck bye-bye okay i have to tell
you that they filmed that video like
four different times so if you want to
give them a shout out in the comments
they were so excited to talk to all you
out there so i'm gonna use a little bit
of both my aunt and my mom i'm gonna do
an orange and i'm gonna do what my aunt
pat said to quarter it sorry mom i'm not
gonna just poke holes this is a pretty
big orange too i don't know if it would
fit in the cavity of our chicken
so we'll cut this in quarters oh this is
a nice
juicy orange i want to eat one right now
oh my god our oranges are ready they
didn't say put an onion in i feel like
they meant to i feel like my mom usually
does i'm gonna put an onion inside i
also it'll infuse it with a ton of
flavor so now it's chicken time we're
gonna pat this guy dry one more time now
i'm gonna take my hand
and lift the skin
and then kind of get my fingers between
the skin and the meat
and loosen that up because we are gonna
wanna get our mayo in there now we're
gonna just take our mayo and rub it all
over like it's at the spa it's a spa
treatment take a clump in your hand
stick it under and massage that in under
the skin the other thing is you can just
put some in and then you can push it up
we'll see if this mayo really works i'm
not saying i'm skeptical kelly but i'm
saying that i'm skeptical our bird
dressed up ready to go the ball i
usually put lemon in my bird but my mom
and aunt swear by orange i do like those
nice and sweet flavors and it smells so
fragrant and then i'm also gonna put one
of my onions up here one of my onion
quarters and then i am gonna go with my
mom on the second one and put rosemary
instead of tarragon when i was at the
store the tarragon was not looking great
rosemary was so my mom wins
to prevent these wings from burning
we're gonna tuck them under the
bird so we're gonna tie up the back legs
this is just gonna keep the moisture in
you don't have to do this chicken's off
to the side and i have got two tips from
my friend carly so the first tip is hey
katie number one don't be afraid of high
heat something like 425 sometimes even
450 will get you the crispiest skin with
the most delicious juicy meat possible
so i usually roast my chicken at 400
degrees we'll see if 425 actually makes
it more crispy and then this next tip
i'm actually very excited about and
number two don't let that render chicken
fat go to waste use it to make the best
croutons you've ever had roast your bird
on top of some torn or cut up bread and
let all of that chicken fat seep in and
just infuse them with flavor
they are going to be amazing so i am so
excited about this because i love
sourdough i love salads i usually roast
my chicken on some potatoes and carrots
and onions but this is gonna be really
fun to try something new i'm just gonna
slice this guy up into quarters
and my mom got me these amazing bread
knives i don't know where they're from
she's a magical person but they're
really great
these guys are looking great they're
about one inch cubes our croutons are
cut so i'm gonna add just a little bit
of olive oil and then we'll add some
salt and i like pepper i'm gonna add
some pepper lastly italian oregano these
are smelling
so good so i'm just gonna add the
croutons to a big casserole dish so this
last tip is for me i like to cut the
tops of whole heads of garlic off and
then put them in whatever i'm roasting
the chicken in it's going to infuse the
bread crumbs it's just going to make
your house smell amazing and then you're
going to be able to toss these
breadcrumbs with the garlic later i'm
doing tofu whole heads because i'm not a
vampire and i love it
i love it now we are so close to the
magic happening all we need to do is set
our chicken on his little bed of bread
i'm gonna put this guy in the oven for
about an hour or until the internal
temperature reaches 165. let's go do
this okay it's time and i've gotta say
the kitchen is smelling amazing
the skin looks really crispy it smells
delicious and all these croutons look
lovely i can't wait to try them we've
got our caesar salad look at that nice
little easy to throw together caesar
salad so what i'm gonna do is take the
chicken off take out that roasted garlic
mix everything together kind of just get
it all fused and delicious and then i'm
gonna throw them in just a little caesar
salad that i made so i'm cutting a slice
and this is
super juicy inside i'm impressed the
skin is not as crispy as a beer can
chicken i've made before but it does
look really yummy you know what a time
it is grass grace we're here it's time
to eat some chicken did you think it was
gonna take two days first of all this
chicken looks gorgeous it's golden brown
it looks really color is very nice it
looks like a picture from a magazine of
food magazine chicken
90s magazine chicken okay i'm just gonna
take that slice because it looks good
cheers cheers
that tastes really really good
you taste multiple things like one at a
time it has a ton of flavors i love the
orange
the orange is delicious but i'm getting
so much flavor i mean like it's very
seasoned sometimes i under season like
the chicken and chris is like katie this
doesn't have enough salt and i'm like
i'm trying to be healthy i'm gonna give
myself a heart
[Laughter]
because we've dry brined it you can
really taste that salt we cook the bird
on bread so these are the croutons that
were cooked under the bread so these are
chicken infused croutons yes
that is a good taste really good this is
a good meal i love the crouton hack
because also now i have some left over
that i can use on a different salad for
tomorrow night i would say it's
definitely up there for me oh wow that
tastes fancy restaurant quality
to me listen everyone likes your songs
you haven't sang a song in a long time a
song do you have a song about roach
chicken chicken brings you the best
friends you will ever have
to go and get some chicken and then
you'll have lots of friends
make sure you leave in the comments what
you do to your chickens because i want
to know okay
bye
bye i didn't help you helped taste it oh
lovely can you take it
oh yes
[Music]
you